I'm joined today by Greg Kading who's a
retired LAPD homicide detective assigned
to solve the homicides of rappers
notorious b.i.g and Tupac Shakur he's
also author of murder rap and the
co-executive producer of USA Network's
newest crime drama unsolved the murders
of Tupac and the notorious b.i.g now a
private investigator Greg thank thanks
for joining us you know when I was
growing up these two murders were two of
these sort of notable murders that got a
lot of attention from really from
culture and society at the time and you
worked on both of these talk just a
little bit about how you got into
working as a homicide detective at LAPD
so I started out with kind of an
emphasis investigative emphasis on gangs
and and of course with gangs always goes
narcotics so that a really strong
background in gang and narcotic
investigations and then of course those
two things are commonly associated with
homicides in Los Angeles a lot of gang
shootings a lot of narcotic related
homicides and so you just kind of
transition into from one investigation
into another and as you gain experience
and and and your investigative skill set
you know you just kind of rise up
towards the more important
investigations which are the you know
homicides okay now when it comes to the
Tupac Shakur investigation talk a little
bit about like what was your day-to-day
I think that a lot of people think they
have an idea of sort of what most of
your day is is like when you're
investigating a homicide but I think
maybe people's assumptions are not
correct like what do you really spend
most of your time doing when you're
looking into a homicide like that of
Tupac Shakur well the Tupac and Biggie
case cuz of course I started out looking
into Biggie's murder not Tupac's because
that was the Los Angeles murder and in
time we kind of found ourselves in the
middle of the Tupac murder investigation
right from the onset they were cold
cases I came on way after the fact I
didn't start investing
until 2006 which was nearly ten years
after Tupac and nine years after biggie
were murdered so there are cold cases
and so we initially had to just try to
absorb all of the investigative material
that had been gathered for that period
of time getting familiar with it all
finding out what's been done what hasn't
been done and then developing an
investigative strategy to take a new
approach at it because everything else
had failed at that point can you talk
about what determines I mean there are
endless cold cases at these major Police
Department's LAPD NYPD any big city has
a ton of cold cases what's sort of the
logic that's applied to decide what cold
cases are we going to look at again well
the way it kind of works is a cold case
once it becomes cold when you when
you've already pursued all of the leads
and all of the kind of conventional
investigative methods once you've
exhausted all of that you have to come
up with something new and genuine and
sometimes it's a result of somebody
calling in with new information where
you get a tip or a lead that you can
then follow up on and hope that it leads
to you know making progress in the case
but other times it's like waiting to see
if there's going to be a DNA hit
eventually it'll connect a cold case to
a recent DNA hit and so they are they're
all they're all different it can be a
new witness coming forward it can be
forensics developing something that you
didn't previously have or it's just
dogged police work where you just keep
going out and constantly you know
reinvestigating people and trying to
kick over every stone that hasn't has
already been turned over as a homicide
investigator is it super clear to you
when you sort of hit the end barring
either new witnesses new evidence or
some kind of forensics like from the
outside many times you see the public
question when a police department says
we've reached the end and we don't
really have anywhere else to go unless
we get new evidence and there's a lot of
disagreement over all the police's
police is handling it correctly or not
but as an actual person doing the
investigation is it pretty clear to you
when you've gone as far as you can go
with the evidence you have yeah you
start to you start this sense that that
you're kind of running out of options
you're running out of leads you're
running out of information that will
propel you forward and it's it's
frustrating but there is a perception
that because these cases aren't being
solved that the police aren't doing
anything and you know there's just
there's conventional investigative
approaches there's things that you know
all homicide detectives will have a
process and have essentially checkboxes
you interview people you look at your
physical evidence you you know you
utilize whatever resources are available
to you and and see what it gets you but
sometimes it just doesn't get you
anywhere so when you started I mean when
you actually started digging into this
case what allowed you to go beyond where
it had been left about a decade prior
well I had somewhat of an advantage
because I had come from working in a
kind of a broader federal context and
working with much better resources than
even the LAPD had at Robbery Homicide
Division and they're well-equipped there
but they don't have all of the funding
and the resources that they need to
really undergo the investigative
strategy that we developed for this case
we needed a lot of money and we needed a
lot of reach to be able to travel and to
buy narcotics and to to do the things
that aren't generally done in in a
standard and homicide investigation so
you know we kind of just took it to a
new level
and brought in a lot of resources that
don't exist in a in a entity like
Robbery Homicide Division so ultimately
who do you believe killed Tupac Shakur
Tupac Shakur was killed by a guy named
Orlando Anderson
he was a South Side [ __ ] from Compton he
was the same guy that she fought
Chikara gotten into a fight with earlier
that night at the MGM in the lobby that
individual along with his crew of gang
members all searched out found Tupac and
shot both him and show and ultimately
what's the evidentiary basis for that in
other words I've seen you say that now
we have factual proof of that what is
that proof that proof comes in the form
of eyewitness testimony not just
eyewitness testimony but comes in the
form of co-conspirator testimony the
individual who shot and killed Tupac
Shakur was in a car along with his uncle
his uncle's name was Keith Iggy Dwayne
Davis also a South Side [ __ ] gang member
and Dwayne Davis was compelled to
cooperate during what we call a proper
session at the US Attorney's Office and
he admitted to his involvement he
admitted to handing the gun to his
nephew who was in the back seat he shot
and killed Orlando so we have an
individual a co-conspirator confessing
to the crime and explaining details that
you wouldn't know about the crime unless
you were actually there so it was a very
validated confession under very
compelling circumstances and it's the
best evidence that there's ever been in
a case where is Orlando Anderson now
Orlando Anderson was killed in 1998
outside of a gas station in Compton on
an unrelated gang incident he was trying
to collect money drug a drug debt from a
couple of guys shooting took place and
Orlando Anderson ended up getting shot
killed you mentioned that these two
investigations that into notorious b.i.g
and Tupac Shakur that these
investigations are linked can you talk
about that a little bit what is the
connection well the connection is that
Biggie Smalls was killed in retaliation
for the shooting of Tupac Shakur in Las
Vegas there was an association between
Bad Boy Records and these South Side
Crips the same ones who killed Tupac
Shakur in Las Vegas there was a business
relationship and an alliance
Bad Boy Records in these crypts and
there was erroneous information that got
out on the streets after Tupac was shot
in Vegas and that information was that
Biggie Smalls had been in Vegas and
these smalls had provided the gun to
these Crips and that he had asked them
to to kill Tupac
that's all erroneous information it was
just Street rumor but it was very close
to the truth because it was actually the
smalls Godfather a guy named Eric Martin
zip who was the one that was in Vegas
and handed the gun to the Crips and
soand solicited them to kill Tupac now
why would he do that in other words why
would the godfather of notorious b.i.g
be in a position where that's something
that he would want to see happen the
killing of Tupac Shakur right so this
individual this Eric Martin who was the
godfather of Christopher Wallace was a
very very close associate with puffy
combs and zip was from Harlem
yeah background in New York is kind of a
street hustler and he was close with
puffy combs in fact one zip dyed puffy
combs spoke at his funeral and there was
a close relationship there and puffy
combs was the one who had actually
previously had a conversation with key
Phoebe and said hey if you can take care
of Big E in two I'm sorry if you can
take care of Suge Knight in Tupac Shakur
I really appreciate it because at that
time there was so much friction going on
between bad boy and death row and
specifically with Suge Knight and puffy
combs puffy combs was aware that cherdon
I was out to kill him and so he kind of
did a preemptive strike by hiring
scripts to protect him and one
particular incident he tells the leader
of the [ __ ] this this guy who's in the
car with the gun listen these guys are
hunting me down I can't afford to come
to LA without worrying about being shot
can you take care of that for me that
leads us to Las Vegas and then the whole
situation is fueled again by the fight
that takes place between Tupac and us
[ __ ] gang member and zip who has the gun
says listen let's kill two birds with
one stone they just jumped your nephew
and beat him down plus puffy wants this
stuff taken care of so let's go handle
it let me talk a little more broadly
since we have you here there are now
pretty clear opposing views when it
comes to how people should sort of carry
on if police or someone like you comes
and wants to talk to them and there are
those who say listen whether you might
be involved or not and whatever the
police want to talk to you about there's
really no benefit to talking because you
might accidentally incriminate yourself
you might end up putting yourself in
sort of a worse position you're always
better off not talking to police unless
you're actually arrested and detained
and sort of even in that case you always
want to have a lawyer present
the counterpoint often is listen if
you're really not involved by talking to
the police you are going to probably
take away attention from you that the
act of not talking in and of itself
might make someone like you a homicide
investigator more focused on a potential
witness or suspect what's the truth
about that in your eyes well it's
actually both of those are true you know
you have to evaluate what is the
person's motive not to talk especially
when you would assume they would be
interested in needing justice in the
case such as the cases with Tupac and
Biggie you would think that their
friends and their entourage would be
doing everything they could in order to
try to bring the killers to justice but
unfortunately in these kind of
subcultures whether it's gangs or you
know street culture they have a code not
to cooperate with the police and they
take on the mentality of like it's it's
not my place just solve this homicide
it's not my place to throw somebody's
name out there and put them on the radar
of law enforcement it's you know let the
cops do their job but they don't
understand there's a needed dynamic
where if we can't get witness
information and witness cooperation and
we can't do our jobs so it's a catch-22
I get the idea that you don't want to
involve yourself in something so
you know dangerous or delicate as a
homicide investigation but at the same
time if we want justice we all have to
you know to to to do our role we all
have to contribute everything that we
can yeah I mean I've never been in a
situation where police have wanted to
talk to me about anything really
anything but certainly nothing as
serious as a homicide and I you know I I
can sort of see it from both sides on
the one hand if I did do something I
definitely would just say I'm not
talking to anybody unless I'm actually
legally compelled to and make them
connect me to whatever crime were
investigating if I didn't know a thing
about it
knowing that police can lie to you
during interrogations knowing everything
I know I still think I might say I just
I don't there's no benefit to me from
going in there and I guess the one
argument that you're making would be
well there might be some societal
benefit to me saying I'm gonna
participate in the system in the process
here but I guess to some risk to me
right well yeah it's a little bit kind
of hypocritical to say I expect the
police to do their jobs and to get
justice in these cases but I won't do my
part
I'm not cooperate and give them what
they need in order to make progress in
this case so you have to decide what you
want to do do you want to demand justice
from the police well also not cooperate
with information that will help the
police get justice or you say it's you
know it's not the police's job if it's
not my job so we all are interdependent
if we want the same thing and that's
justice very very interesting we've been
speaking with retired LAPD homicide
detective Greg Kading Greg really
appreciate you talking to me today
absolutely my pleasure have a great day